our students are undergraduate students
look like us but they're fundamentally
different than us that is they've grown
up in a technology-rich visually rich
environment they were not passive
learners in k-12 school and they come to
columbia with new expectations of
heightened expectations about what
teaching involves they don't want for
the most pirated teacher-centered
classrooms they want learner-centered
classrooms and that involves a lot of
change and trying to find ways to
continue the strengths of the past but
to connect better to these students this
has been the great challenge and it's
been an exciting challenge in its one
that I think everyone has been a fool I
mean everyone that I've encountered has
a sense that we're in happening a new
world educationally and we need to
figure out what works in that role
students read and research online how do
we get them in the library students not
only want to create traditional research
papers but many students are eager to
create new kinds of projects web based
projects that involve hypertext or
digital stories that is many movies and
I want to prepare the teachers of the
next generation the professor's of the
next generation to be able to teach in
those new ways and really meet the
expectations of the new students that
were encountering one thing about
childhood and adolescence is that for
most young people there were no
irretrievable
mistakes no irretrievable failures no
irretrievable losses but for adults
every decision sends us in one direction
and closes a lot other options and I'm
interested in how Americans throughout
our history from the colonial period to
now have wrestled with those challenges
of adulthood my sort of broader theme is
that our popular conception of adulthood
maturity responsibility seriousness was
a product of the 19th century that is it
accompanied the rise of
industrialization and then it began to
break down in the 1950s and 1960s and
now we live in an era where the very
meaning of adulthood is quite uncertain
and we don't any longer know what it
means to grow up we want to grow that
girl unless question really quick on the
subject just removing phonetic on you
know I guess you know these everybody
loves these lists you can reach the
movies that you've really personal
knowledge as well but I'm recent movies
you've really enjoyed so those things
that you can see having you know being
taught in class 10 years from now 15 20
years from now most of the movies that I
go to see are at the Lincoln Center Film
Society and so their films that are not
going to get huge play and sometimes
their way out of time sequence so I just
saw Omar Sharif as che in a 1969 version
which was just wonderful
claude lelouch was on campus last
semester and showed his new and it was
fabulous it had a very short run in
theaters and people really missed it I
would have told erie something I can
okay okay but I just loved it and that's
of course what Columbia's best half here
in a little room on campus you have one
of the deans of French film with you
know a small group of film fanatics and
he's screening it it's not a theater
it's a fairly large screen but not a
serial screen the sound systems fine but
not great but you have all this film
intensity and you have one of the great
directors and where else could this
happen anyplace else it sure certainly
didn't happen to me elsewhere well well
it I mean it's great that you're looking
good Sam it sounds like you finally
found the right place job you know